SPEAKER: 86% of
app ideas are born
from a developer's
personal pain.
These ideas are for
apps nobody needs.
Developers believe research
with users is a waste of time.
They perceive their app
as a coding exercise.
To validate their idea, they ask
their sister if she likes it.
She says yes.
TOMER SHARON: Meet
Will and Dana.
Will and Dana are the
co-founders of Noteo,
a note-taking app nobody needs.
Dana is 26 years old.
She's an MIT Computer Science
graduate, she's a Trekkie,
and she has been coding since
she was eight years old.
Will is 25 years old.
He's a Stanford Computer
Science graduate,
and he loves Star
Wars and LEGOs.
They met over a
weekend hack-a-thon
here in San Francisco
about a year ago,
and they liked each
other's way of thinking.
So about six months
ago, they started Noteo,
and they've been
working on it since.
Will and Dana are failing.
They're crashing,
they're burning,
and they're sinking
$200,000 of seed money
that they got, without even
knowing what went wrong.
I'm here to help you
avoid their mistakes.
execute the right plan.
Hi, my name is Tomer Sharon.
I'm a Google Search User
Experience Researcher,
and I have been studying
dozens of thousands
of users, of people.
Learning about what they
need, what they want,
and how they use apps
and other products.
I've been helping Google Search
and startup teams come up
with products that
meet human needs.
Going back to Will and Dana.
They have six big, big problems.
Their number one is they did
not fall in love with a problem.
They rushed into
launching a landing page
for a product they
weren't sure of.
They had personal pains
related to note-taking,
and they were sure that this
is something people needed.
Just to be very sure, they
launched this landing page.
And I did put an arrow here, but
I'm going to use my lightsaber.
They launched this landing page.
And they collected
people's email addresses,
trying to figure out
if they're interested,
therefore if the app is needed.
But the only question that
they were able to answer
is the one that
you see down there.
Are people interested
enough to give them
their email addresses?
They were never getting
or gathering information
about what users need.
Their number two problem is
that they learned from friends.
They interviewed seven
friends and family members.
Now family members
and friends are always
happy to give you feedback.
The problem is that
they're biased.
How can they hurt your feelings?
They're your friends.
They're your family.
Of course they like your idea.
Sure, they'll use it.
No doubt they'll pay for it.
A lot.
Third problem.
They listened to users.
Now I know coming from a
User Experience Researcher,
it sounds kind of weird,
but bear with me here.
The first rule of research
is don't listen to users.
Instead, observe their behavior.
When Will and Dana asked
their friends and family,
would you use this app,
would you pay for it,
how much you pay for it,
they got really good answers.
People liked it.
But they forgot--
or didn't know,
or ignored-- what
social psychologists
know for almost 100 years now.
We humans are very, very bad
at predicting our own behavior.
Here are two studies that
were done during that time.
This is a study from 1937.
The researchers
went into classrooms
and asked students-- they
passed along a questionnaire--
and they asked students,
would you cheat in an exam?
And the students answered.
A few weeks after that, they
came back to these classes,
to these students, and
together with the teachers,
they were giving an
opportunity for the students
to cheat without them knowing.
And surprise,
surprise, there was
close to zero correlation
between what people said
about their behavior and
what they actually did.
1937.
Now Will is kind of
sarcastic about studies
from 77 years ago, so
here's a study from 2012.
This was done in the UK with
dozens of thousands of people.
The researchers went into public
bathrooms in gas stations.
And they asked people
coming out of the bathrooms,
did you wash your hands after
you finished your business?
99% percent of people
said of course, yes.
But the researchers, they
installed electronic recording
devices on the faucets
in the bathrooms.
And they actually knew
exactly how many people
did wash their hands.
So 32% of men and 64% of women
actually did wash their hands.
There's a very, very big
difference-- very big
difference-- between what we say
we do and what we actually do.
There are many reasons for that.
Some people would say,
they're just liars.
They're not.
We are having trouble
predicting our behavior.
There are many reasons for that.
When Will and Dana ask
their friends and family,
or anyone else, would
you use our app?
They're asking them
to predict the future.
Again, we humans
are very bad at it.
Their fourth
problem is that they
didn't test the
riskiest assumption.
Every product or
idea comes with a set
of assumptions or beliefs.
The riskiest assumption is the
one that is core to the idea.
And it's also unknown.
Or, the riskiest assumption,
if that's not true--
if the riskiest
assumption is not true--
the whole idea falls apart.
What they could have
done, Will and Dana, is--
and this is just
an example-- they
could have assumed
that this is risky.
Smartphone owners are aware of
their ineffective note-taking
habits.
If this is not true, they have
no reason to develop Noteo.
They didn't do anything
to validate or invalidate
this riskiest assumption.
Their fifth problem
is what I call,
that they're having a Bob
the Builder mentality.
They rushed into
developing a product.
This is what they know best.
This is what they
know how to do.
They rushed to
developing a product,
and they launched a
minimum viable product
without even knowing what for.
They kept asking themselves, can
we build this note-taking app,
instead of asking
if they should.
In their mind, this
was a coding exercise.
And a coding exercise
doesn't require any insights
from users.
And their last problem is
that they were perfectly
executing the wrong plan.
They developed a beautiful
app nobody needs.
They could have validated
or invalidated three things.
The problem.
Is there a problem,
a note-taking problem
in this world that
people care about?
They could have
validated the market.
Are there enough people who
have this problem and care
about this problem?
And later on, they could
have validated their product.
Is our product solving this
problem for this market?
And I give credit
to Laura Klein,
who's sitting right here.
Thanks for that.
They are doing a few
things very well.
I want to mention
two of these things.
So in the past year, I
interviewed 150 app developers
and startup founders.
And I wanted to know what are
the questions that they ask
themselves about their
users, or potential users.
And the good thing
that I found was
that they ask the
right questions.
These are some of the results.
I'm just going to
go over a couple.
97% of them ask, who
are my customers?
95% ask, do people
need my product?
Probably the most
important question to ask.
89% ask if the
product is usable.
These are very good and
important questions to ask.
The second thing that
is going well for them
is that they
understand priorities.
They understand what
are the questions, what
are the most important
questions they need to ask.
And they know when to
ask these questions.
I'm completely ignoring
the invalid, unreliable way
they answered those questions.
But just having
the right questions
and knowing when to ask them
is a very, very positive thing.
So up until now, I talked
about their six problems
and a couple of good
things for them.
What I want to do next
is suggest a solution.
Suggest a way to
execute the right plan.
So say hello to
lean user research.
Lean user research
is a discipline
that is providing
insights into product
users, their perspectives, and
abilities to the right people
at the right time.
Excellent lean user
research is of high quality.
It's not crappy research.
It's impactful, meaning
it's not just interesting,
but you actually have
something to do with it.
And it's fast, because nobody
wants to wait for research.
Next, I'm going to introduce
you to three lean user research
techniques.
The first one is called
experience sampling,
the second is observation,
and the third is fake doors.
Let's start with
experience sampling.
During an experience
sampling study,
research participants are
interrupted several times a day
to note their
experience in real time.
This is a very unique way
of mining their reality.
Experience sampling is coming
from a research technique
that was called pager studies.
This was developed in the 1950s.
Back then, researchers
handed pagers
to their research subjects
and asked them a question
several times a day.
For example, how do you feel?
Where are you?
And things like that.
Or what do you do?
And they collected
these responses
and understood the lives
of their users, or research
subjects.
The key in experience sampling
is asking the same question
over and over again.
So for example, if you want
to know-- if you ask people,
what annoyed you in the
last couple of hours?
Imagine you asked that
question five times a day,
for five days, and you have
100 research participants.
Quick math, you collect
2,500 data points.
This is a huge, huge,
insightful, useful body
of knowledge.
I want you to try it out.
If you sit nearby the screen,
you can use the QR code.
If not, access
this URL right now.
Yes, do it right now.
And even if you watch at
home, you can do that.
And you have an experience
sampling question there.
A sample question
related to Noteo.
It works!
Answer the question, and
we'll go over your answers
in a minute.
And I'm going to play
with my lightsaber.
Don't futz with it too much.
The URL is working too.
All right, I'm moving on.
So imagine you are asked that
question five times a day,
for five days.
You're not always going
to have an answer,
but you will in many cases.
Let's go over sample responses.
So here we have 31
responses to this question.
If you look at it-- just eyeball
what you see here-- very,
very quickly you can
understand that there
are several groups of
things you can learn here.
Let me color them for you.
Some people are
writing down lists.
Others are writing down ideas.
And others are just
sketching stuff.
That's from a few
seconds of looking at it.
Imagine 2,000 of these and
what you can learn from that.
One of the most important
things in experience sampling
is the question that you
ask, phrasing it right.
A great experience
sampling question
asks about repeated behavior.
Something that happens
a lot during a day,
or during the study period.
I'm going to give
examples in a minute.
A bad experience
sampling question
is asking either
yes/no questions.
Yes/no would give you
nothing about user needs.
It would give you 2,500
responses of yes or no.
You're not going to
learn much from that.
A bad question also
can ask about numbers.
Again, same thing.
You're going to get
a lot of numbers,
you're going to
average them, it's not
going to tell you much
about what people need.
And a bad question also
asks about opinion.
If you ask me eight times
a day about my opinion
about something, it's
not going to change much.
All right?
Ask about repeated behaviors.
Two examples.
A good example.
What was the reason you
recently updated your website?
Repeated behavior, no data, no
numerical data, not yes or no,
and it's not about an opinion.
It's about behavior.
A bad example.
How many emails did you
receive in the past hour?
Some people would say
0, 3, 17, 52, 200.
Again, there's not
a lot you can learn
from that about user needs.
So to sum it up,
experience sampling
helps you identify needs.
It identifies
features that might
be helpful for your audience.
And it tells you a lot
about current pain points
and delights.
So this was experience sampling.
I'm moving on to observation.
This is the second lean
user research technique
I want to introduce you to.
In observation,
you are gathering
data at the user's or
the person's environment.
They don't have to be users yet.
This is the science
of contextualization.
There are four pillars
to observation.
The first one, pretty
obvious, is observing.
Watching people as they go
along with their daily lives,
at home, work, the
street, the bus station,
the train, wherever
is relevant, based
on what you want to learn.
The second pillar is listening.
Listening to the jargon
people use, their language,
and witnessing conversations
they have with one another.
Third, noticing.
There are several
behaviors, or things
that happen, that you
can observe and identify
that would tell you a lot
about what people need.
And gathering.
You collect artifacts.
Artifacts are things
people either use
or create to
complete their tasks.
So for example, if you're
observing a person at work,
and a work related
task is coming in,
and the person is noting
that task in a spreadsheet
they created, that's a
spreadsheet you need to gather.
I talked about
noticing behaviors.
I want to go over
several such behaviors.
Paying attention
to these behaviors
is really, really hard.
I don't know if
you're aware of it,
but when you observe
people, there
are tons of things
you can learn.
It's critical to know
what to look for.
So here are just
five behaviors that
are important to
pay attention to.
The first one is routines,
regular actions people
are doing.
The task example I just
gave, with the spreadsheet,
this is a routine.
Interruptions.
When something happens and it
stops a person-- the person
you're watching-- stops
them from completing a task.
Breaking its
continuity in some way,
either because of the
person himself or herself,
or because of someone
else, can teach you a lot.
Life is never clean
of interruptions.
If a phone call is
coming in, the person
is in a meeting, looks at
the phone, takes the call.
As an observer,
your intuition would
be to ignore that
because you didn't
want to learn about meetings.
But what happens during
that conversation
is extremely important
to learn from.
It has a direct
relationship to what
you want to learn
about the meeting.
Annoyances.
Annoyances are just
obstacles to complete a task.
They're not going to prevent
people from completing a task,
but they would make them angry.
They would make them
overwhelmed, frustrated,
and things like that.
Delights.
A lot of people
think that research
is there to identify problems,
challenges, pain points.
That's partially true.
Learning about what
people love, learning
about what people
enjoy, is extremely
helpful in understanding
what they need.
And the last behavior to pay
attention to is transitions.
This is what happens when the
thing you're observing is done,
or on the way to something else.
I'll give an example, because
it better explains it.
Let's say, again, you're
interested in meetings
and you're observing a
person during a work day.
And they have a meeting.
The meeting has
ended, and now they're
walking 200 feet to
the next meeting.
Your intuition would be to
take a break, a mental break.
Drink water, check
your email, not
pay attention to
what's happening.
But that person might
open their laptop
and walk to that
meeting doing something.
This is a very, very
good signal for a need.
So pay attention to
these transitions.
Instead of just talking
about observation,
let's watch 90 seconds of
an observation session.
What I want you to do is this.
Imagine that Stop & Shop, a
grocery shopping retailer,
came to you and asked you
to answer this question.
How can we improve the in-store
grocery shopping experience
with technology?
Try and list, or think
about, three things
that she really,
really cares about.
Let's watch.
WOMAN SPEAKER: And
another thing that I do
is, if something is
really a good price--
if something's on sale and
it's for a really good deal--
and it's not perishable, or
that it has an expiration
date that's farther
along, I'll buy a bunch.
Like, I literally--
if I know my kids love
it-- and I know that
it's an amazing price-- I
buy like 10 of something.
For example, the other day I
bought Haagen-Dazs ice cream.
I see that it's on sale now.
I'm biased.
Haagen-Dazs is just really
good quality ice cream,
and there's a lot of flavors,
and my kids love ice cream.
So to me, sometimes
quality is important,
even though you're
paying a little bit more.
So I bought the Haagen-Dazs
ice cream at a good price
because then you save-- two for
$7.00-- you save $0.99 each.
So you're actually saving
$2.00 when you're paying $7.00
for two.
So I loaded up my cart.
You know, Haagen-Dazs
doesn't do a bigger size,
so of course you're paying more.
MALE SPEAKER: How
do you know this
is a good price compared
to other places?
WOMAN SPEAKER: Good question.
Just because, in my
experience, I've seen
Haagen-Dazs being sold, and
it's usually the full price
that it says that it is.
It's at least $4.50.
For example, King's, the high
end market down the street,
everything's more expensive
in here, baseline.
So one time, my husband
liked the Greek yogurt,
and I wanted to buy him
the Greek yogurt when
I was at King's, and
they had a little sale.
And I was so happy, and I
bought a bunch, and I came home.
And when I came
here to Stop & Shop
and I looked at
the Greek yogurt,
it was cheaper baseline
than it was at--
TOMER SHARON: At King's.
All right.
So, in 90 seconds,
these are three insights
you could have learned.
She cares about
saving money, she
cares about the quality
of the food she's buying,
and she cares about
her kids' health.
Imagine what you could have
learned during a longer
session with several people.
All right?
Observation is really good
for identifying features
your users or
potential users need,
for validating or invalidating
assumptions about your users,
and learning more about their
problems, workflows, and goals.
So this was observation.
The third, and last, lean
user research technique
I want to go over is called fake
doors, or as I like to call it,
fake it till you make it.
And fake doors-- and
I'm using, again,
Will and Dana's
landing page-- you
are pretending you
have something.
They did that in their
other landing page,
where they tried to
collect email addresses.
The difference here
is this button.
Instead of collecting
email addresses,
they are trying to
understand the commitment.
They're trying to
prove that there's
a commitment to
using the product.
They're asking people to buy a
product that doesn't exist yet.
If people do that,
that's a very good signal
that there's a need here.
A version of that is called
the button to nowhere.
The button to nowhere is
exactly what it sounds like.
I'm going back to this page.
Imagine that Will and Dana
thought about they had an idea.
Let's develop a TV
app for note-taking.
Now without writing-- well,
maybe not one line of code,
because adding this button
right there would take
a line of code-- but without
writing a lot of code,
without developing the app, they
can learn a lot about needs.
What they need to do is
measure, or look at the ratio,
between how many people
clicked the button divided
by how many people are
exposed to this page.
If they decide in
advance on a threshold,
that if crossed that would
make them develop the app,
they have a very powerful
decision making tool at hand.
And they didn't need to develop
anything else, rather than
this.
They don't need to
develop the product.
This technique is also
called 404 testing,
for obvious reasons.
And it's extremely helpful
in learning about needs
without risking time, money, and
effort you can never get back
if you develop
the wrong product.
So lean user research technique.
I talked about experience
sampling, observation,
and fake doors.
And lean user research
is a discipline
that is providing
insights into products
users, their perspectives, and
abilities to the right people
at the right time.
[LAUGHTER]
Funny, but when you talk about
apps, it's not funny anymore.
Ignore lean user research,
and your app's destiny
will be very similar to
the destiny of helicopters
in movies.
Many developers think
that they don't have time
to waste on learning from users.
If there's one thing,
only one thing,
I want you to take
away from this talk,
is that you don't have time
to develop the wrong app.
Don't perfectly
execute the wrong plan.
Execute the right plan.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
A couple of things.
Feedback on this talk
would be extremely helpful.
And I want to thank
all these good people
for serving as the photographer,
logo designer, models,
and so on and so forth.
If you have any questions,
please come to the mics here,
and I'll be happy to answer.
We have enough time.
Or you can come to me.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1: I've got two.
So, suppose our
team's getting bigger.
Same customer base.
Could be like we're working
on exposure touch point A,
and the other team's working
on touch point B. Is there
strategies or
approaching for sharing
findings and results of user
researches to other team
members?
And then, probably the
second one, that is,
do findings and
research results expire?
TOMER SHARON: Sharing
is key to success.
I mean, I don't
see why you don't
share your findings
with other teams.
Are you competing?
Are the teams competing?
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1: No, no, no.
The question is how.
TOMER SHARON: How to share?
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1: Yeah.
Well, I mean-- So I actually
have to hand someone raw data.
That's part of the
[? parser, ?] where
I can make [INAUDIBLE]
for them to gain
meaningful insights [INAUDIBLE].
TOMER SHARON: OK,
so the question
is asking about what to share.
All right.
I'm against reports, so I'm
not for writing reports.
But do do the analysis and
share what you learned from it.
You don't need to
drop raw data on them.
What was the other question?
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1: Do
findings ever expire?
TOMER SHARON: Do
Sometimes if you
change the design,
if you change the product,
some findings might expire.
Finding about human behavior
don't tend to expire.
Findings about user needs
don't really expire.
Because human behavior-- and
I know it's a funny thing--
doesn't change much.
We are behaving very similarly
to how humans behaved
10,000 years ago
without technology.
Yes.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 2: So
what is the right sample
size for any kind of
research like this?
So for a small application,
what would the sample size be?
For a bigger application
with more risk,
what would the sample size be?
TOMER SHARON: It depends
on your question.
Remember, the
questions I introduced?
For observation, you don't
need a lot of people.
And not a lot is, I don't
know, eight, or around that
are more than enough
to learn from.
In experience sampling,
when I'm doing that,
we use thousands now.
We used to use hundreds,
now we're using thousands.
It depends on what
you want to know
and what is the research
method that you're picking.
But it's changing.
If you have a specific
question in mind
that you want to
learn about, I'm
happy to talk to you later
about the sample size.
Yes.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 3: Hi, I
thought your observation
example was very interesting.
It looked a lot like the
listening to your users thing
that you told us never to do.
TOMER SHARON: When I say,
don't listen to users,
observe their behavior, there
are two ways to do that.
I didn't go into that
because I didn't have time,
but I am happy to do that now.
What you watched is what I
call an out loud session.
What I asked her to do is
describe what she's doing.
I didn't ask her for-- you
know, I didn't ask her,
would you use the app
I'm thinking about?
I didn't ask her for
feature recommendations.
I asked her to describe
what she's doing and why.
OK?
Another way of doing
that is what I call,
do it in silent mode.
Ask them to shut up.
People usually don't talk to
themselves when they shop,
so you can just watch.
It's a trade off.
There are pros and
cons to each one.
Because when you watch someone--
I have a video of someone
I asked not to talk during
shopping, grocery shopping--
you don't really
understand what's going on.
It seems very unhelpful.
So sometimes, in
some situations,
I do ask them to describe
what they're doing.
Sometimes I'll do some
kind of combination.
I ask them to be
silent, and only
if I don't understand
something, I'll
ask them a question about it.
I'll ask them to explain.
Don't listen to users when you
ask questions about the future.
OK?
If you have no choice, ask
them about the recent past, not
about the future.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 3: On a closely
related note, the first thing
I noticed in that example
was that the user couldn't
get through 90
seconds of shopping
without being interrupted
by somebody yelling
on a loudspeaker about something
she cared nothing about.
TOMER SHARON: Yeah,
it's like flying.
Yes.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 4:
So with 404 testing,
what are some of the pitfalls?
It seems like if I
put a button in my app
and pushed that out to everyone,
that they're going to be upset.
TOMER SHARON: There's one
very, very big pitfall.
I attended one of Eric Ries's
talk, and he gives an example.
Or, somebody asked
him, what do you
mean post an ad that
leads to nowhere?
To a 404 page?
People would chase me.
People would call
me, and they would
want to do bad things to me.
And he responded and said,
then you have a business.
They really care.
So the con is that the
people feel tricked.
So, I'm not recommending that
you do that all the time.
But sometimes this is extremely
helpful in understanding needs.
You can be more gentle
than serving 404 pages
and come up with something
like I showed, coming soon,
or something like that.
Thank you for your
feedback, you helped us.
If you have money, pay them.
Things like that.
Give them a gift or
something like that
to make it better for them.
Yes.
AUDIENCE MEMBER
5: I was wondering
if you have any recommendations
for conducting the user
experience sampling?
Just in terms of
implementation-wise.
Do I just put
dialogues in my app
after the users execute
some repeated action, or?
TOMER SHARON: I do have
a lot to say about that.
What I'm going to say is
that tomorrow at 9 o'clock,
I'm giving a talk just
about experience sampling.
So instead of three
minutes, I have 30 minutes,
so I'm going to talk
more about that.
And I'm going to talk about
an example from Google.
AUDIENCE MEMBER
5: OK, thank you.
TOMER SHARON: Sure.
Yes.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 6: How do you
pick your riskiest assumption?
TOMER SHARON: Again,
it's an assumption.
It's not easy.
First, you need a
list of assumptions.
A lot of people
don't even do that.
List of assumptions.
And then, look at
each one and try
and think-- if you
have a team, do
that as a team-- try to
identify the one assumption
that if it turns out
that it's not true,
everything falls apart.
There's no reason
for this company,
there's no reason
for this product.
Might be more than one, but
normally it's about one.
All right?
Yep.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 7: Hi.
I was wondering, what is
your advice for a redesign
or a product that
exists already,
but you want to improve?
And maybe you kind of executed
it in not the best way?
TOMER SHARON: That's
a pet peeve of mine.
Usually, redesigns,
from my observations,
are done because
three years passed.
And it's not necessarily
a good reason.
There needs to be a good
reason for a redesign.
If it's from 15 years
ago and it looks old,
that's a good reason.
Three years ago, I'm not
sure it's going to look old.
A good reason is, we identified
different user needs.
OK?
And identified user needs is not
we asked people what they need,
and they told us.
Or feature requests.
Or things like that.
User needs bubble up from
these things I just described.
AUDIENCE MEMBER
7: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 8:
You can let them go.
They've been-- OK.
TOMER SHARON: No, no, I
give priority to women
because we want
them to come back.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 8: So, really,
we're talking apps here.
But a product is a product.
Hardware, software, it
doesn't matter what it is.
One's a little more
permanent than another.
But how do you end up
finding the right problem,
executing it correctly, but
not doing it the correct way?
So, this is something-- I do
a lot of stuff with startups
and I see this happen all
the time-- and I just go,
this product is useless to me
because it solves the problem,
but it doesn't solve
it in a way that's
going to be continuously useful.
Or it's too expensive.
How do you find that out early
on in the stages of development
and ideation in order to
prevent that kind of outcome?
TOMER SHARON: One thing that
I mentioned during the talk
is something that people
in many cases ignore.
It's not only important
to identify a problem,
because there are many
problems in this world.
It's important to
identify and invest time
in identifying a problem
people really care about.
Because there are many
problems that nobody
would argue that
they're problems,
but people don't care enough
about them to solve them.
We do a lot of
bypasses all day long.
We don't really care.
Yes, there's a problem.
No big deal.
There are hundreds of thousands
of apps that solve problems
that nobody cares about.
I would say this is key.
You can solve the right problem,
you can solve a problem people
care about, and you can
design a beautiful app,
but then the
workflow is terrible,
and people would never use it.
There are problems, from
the company or the startup
perspectives, that can
arise in every stage.
In my opinion,
the hardest to fix
is solving the wrong problem.
Or not solving any problem.
There are many solutions
without problems.
OK?
It's hard.
It's not something I
can answer in a minute.
We can talk later.
Yes.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 9:
Does this change
if you're building an enterprise
software instead of a consumer
application?
For example, there are two
big differences that I see.
One is there are
multiple stakeholders.
And number two, the access
to top management is limited,
or perhaps the intentions of
managers are opaque sometimes.
TOMER SHARON: I always
like to talk about research
in terms of questions.
If you care about
what people need,
what people want, and
can they use the thing,
it's not really different.
What product, what app, or what
organization you're targeting.
Or what type of audience
you're targeting.
Of course, there are
differences in the details.
Differences in
stakeholders, definitely.
In organizations, there is
the person or department
that pays for the product,
and then there are users.
That's different.
They have very different
considerations.
So yes, there are differences.
And when you have
multiple stakeholders,
you need to focus
on each one of them.
Because user experience is not
just what happens to the user
during the usage of the product.
But very basically, there's
not a lot of difference.
The basic things you
need to do, there's
not a lot of difference,
in my opinion, at least.
Yep.
AUDIENCE MEMBER
10: So what do you
do when your users have a
need that happens much less
frequently than taking
notes or going shopping,
like buying a flight?
TOMER SHARON: Good question.
So I mentioned, what was
the reason you recently
updated your website?
People don't necessarily
update their website
five or eight times a day.
So the study would
just take longer.
So let's say your audience is
updating their website twice
a week.
All right?
So you're not going to
ask that five times a day.
I would recommend that
you ask that once a week
and run this study for 10 weeks.
All right, so, a participant
would answer the question
during a study 10
times over 10 weeks.
Do that with 50,
100 people, you have
a lot of data points still.
It's just going to take longer.
Yep.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 11: Hi.
How do you deal with insincere
answers to your questions?
How do you--
TOMER SHARON: I
ask more questions.
In my interviews with
founders and app developers,
I wanted to know if
they read certain books.
And I thought in
advance that they
would tend to not say
the truth because they
want to look smart.
So I asked them, after
asking about the books,
so say three questions
after that, I asked them
what does the term blah,
blah, blah say to you.
And that's a term taken from
an important book in that list.
If they haven't
read the book, they
wouldn't know what
I was talking about.
And some of them didn't.
So there are ways to understand
if people are not very sincere.
But there's an
even bigger problem
when you ask people and
not observe their behavior.
When you ask people, they do
what's called rationalization.
They tell you things
they think you
want to hear because
they want to look smart.
They want to be
perceived as good people.
So they would change
reality a little bit.
And the bad news is
that we have no way
of knowing if
that's true or not.
So it's hard.
It's hard.
That's why I heartily
recommend not
to ask questions
and just watch them.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 11: Thank you.
TOMER SHARON: Last question.
We don't have time.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 12: It's
regarding the 404 testing.
Most of the time, you are
just pitching something new.
It's hard to get data
from your competitions.
How do you generalize the
data that you have collected,
since you don't
have anything that
is similar to what
you're trying to do?
TOMER SHARON: Let me
see if I understand.
You are saying that you don't
have anything to compare to?
AUDIENCE MEMBER 12: Probably.
TOMER SHARON: OK,
so you can decide
in advance, what
is a number that
would make us feel confident?
Or you can compare yourself
to yourself over time.
So you can run the test
today, and then again a month
from now, and in two months,
and see what has changed,
if at all.
OK?
All right, one more.
I have a timer here, and
something will explode if--
AUDIENCE MEMBER 13: All right,
I'll try to keep it tight.
The lady in the video
seemed like an extrovert.
And it seems like these
would be the kind of people
who would be more
inclined to participate
in an observational study.
Do you have any methods
for recruiting introverts,
or making sure that
there isn't a bias there?
TOMER SHARON: Yes.
When you find these
people, don't just
communicate with
them over email.
Talk to them.
All right?
And many people
would not volunteer
even if you're paying.
They would not volunteer
themselves to do that.
But if you talk to them, you
can create rapport and make
them feel comfortable,
and some would come.
You don't have to
have-- that woman
is what we researchers
call a good participant.
Because she's really, you
know, expressing everything
in a very clear way.
It's very easy for us to learn
from these kinds of people.
But we also need the introverts.
So we talk to them in
advance, to make sure
that they're
comfortable with it.
And not all of them will.
Sometimes we do
blind observations.
We observe people
without them knowing.
We just walk-- let's say the
grocery shopping-- we just
walk into a store.
I was in a sports
bar a month ago
watching people watch games.
And they didn't even know
I was doing research.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 13: One more.
Do you find that there's
kind of a certain period
through the session that after
which, then you kind of really
start in your mind
recording interactions,
because you've warmed up the
participant, so to speak?
TOMER SHARON: What do
you mean, recording?
AUDIENCE MEMBER 13: Or like,
you might need to warm them up
before you can kind of get the
behaviors you want, I guess.
TOMER SHARON: Yes.
They need to feel comfortable.
So I pretty much in the first
five, ten, fifteen minutes,
sometimes, I don't
really collect any data.
I just want to make them feel
comfortable sharing stuff
with me, or just getting
used to the odd situation
that you do grocery
shopping with somebody
with a camera following you.
And there are ways to make
them feel comfortable.
All right.
So, for those of
you who are here,
you don't have time to
work on the wrong app.
Please, please, please perfectly
execute the right plan.
Thanks guys.